here's the thing I'm not letting
opportunities Pass Me By would you give
your phone number to Jim
well it was somebody's son
somebody's son gonna love me one day
y'all know that song If you don't just
know it's a good one what's not to like
about them yes gin Rebel she's
interested in dating Debbie's son Julian
even just seeing him with the care that
he shows for her I just felt his Vibe
and I know some of y'all aren't really
feeling Debbie right now but I think we
all can agree that she did her thing
with matchmaking Jen and Julian well let
me not speak too soon I'm just excited
because it feels like a normal
relationship how often do we see couples
that make sense on 90 day
exactly plus
it looks like somebody else's son isn't
telling the truth when it comes to
finances Danielle and Johan go back and
forth about who pays rent Danielle is
that true do you guys know split things
50 50. now the the okay no
yeah we don't spend everything and after
Danielle's ex Talon joins the tell-all
Johan says he no longer wants to be with
her yeah
oh please please rethink this it's
fixable is it though Debbie
let's talk about it
hey naughty day fans fam it's melicia I
hope you are doing well the other way
season four is officially a wrap but
before we get into Jen and Julian and
Johann and Danielle
oh they are a lot I want to say draining
but words are powerful so we're gonna
stick with a lot but anyway before we
get to them here are a few quick updates
Gabe and his sister Monica made up after
she flew all the way to Colombia to
attend his wedding to Isabel only not to
show up to the wedding because she had
an argument with Gabe the night before
the reason gave that I didn't show up
and the reason why I was hurt was
because you said to me
that I'm the common denominator in all
of your field relationships
that's it okay well it hurt her feelings
and her feelings are valid but honestly
I think there might be a deeper sibling
issue going on between Gabe and Monica
that has nothing to do with his choice
in women that's just my thought but one
thing is clear they love each other and
luckily Gabe and Isabel plan on having a
second wedding ceremony at some point in
the states and they would love for
Monica to be a part of it by the way
Monica is wearing the dress she was
supposed to wear to Gabe's wedding in
Columbia she said I am not letting this
go to waste she looks beautiful I love
emerald green that is my color alright
moving on to Mahmoud and his brother
laughing as Nicole talks about going
through his phone and catching him
texting with a girl from China she sells
some stuff and they were shutting for
getting some stuff from here and somehow
I asked how old are you I don't I know I
shall don't ask that but I did what can
you see what do you like to watch oh how
old are you oh
um what are you doing right now
Nicole is a different breed because hell
no this whole scene feels like a mom
talking about catching her teenage son
texting his little girlfriend now I know
Nicole is my mood's first relationship
but just because he's a newbie to all of
this doesn't make the first time he
tries to flirt with another woman behind
his wife's back adorable or innocent I
just sit ask you the question I should
not no it was more than two questions
would you definitely cross some cross
some lines there no no no no no yes I
was totally inappropriate and you know
it what kind of TV shows do you like oh
I watch Egyptian TV and sometimes
American TV
I don't get why they think this is so
funny like this sometimes chat sometimes
when we sat or fight we love we love
look it might be part of their culture
to laugh during hard times I don't know
but I know I didn't see my mood laughing
when he was fighting with Nicole on the
street and his brother sure wasn't
laughing when he came in to save the day
sometimes
when we sat or five
that whole conversation was just
different and then Gabe puts his two
cents in I think you're so scummy
words from my wife
Mahmoud has everything in a man that I
would never want dang just throw Isabel
under the bus why didn't you let her say
that Gabe so Gabe what would your advice
to Nicole be
my advice to Nicole is to get a divorce
yeah well my mood is set to make to Los
Angeles to try living here with Nicole
and the state
I'm looking forward to seeing how all of
that plays out onto some hopeful news
Jen gushes over Debbie's son Julian
revealing to Gabe that she gave him her
number after this moment during part one
of the tell-all didn't you think Jen was
kind of cute and nice do you think she
kind of was like batting her eyes at you
a little bit will you mind my number you
can give it to her okay well apparently
Debbie made something Shake I try not to
get nosy into his business okay but I
want him to be happy and have a future
and then seems to be excited about
getting to know Julian saying she
doesn't want to allow Rishi to make her
miss out on good opportunities what made
you want to give your number to him like
what do you like about him what's not to
like about him from the get-go like even
just seeing him with the care that he
shows for her I just felt his Vibe
they say get you a man who loves and
knows how to treat his mama and speaking
of vibes from what we've seen I think
Julian would also fit in nicely with
Jen's family he's an attractive guy he's
my age like you know it was probably a
couple years younger than me but my
career too yes got a career like just
seems like a legit somebody that I could
have a conversation with could she not
have a conversation with Rishi
I pressed about marrying a man she can't
even talk to I think it's good that
you're testing the waters because I
don't know if rishi's the one for you
yeah I I do feel like to a certain
extent there is something to be said for
somebody that lives in the same country
and his family doesn't already hate me
oh I'm happy for her it feels good to
have a new quality Prospect all right
let's talk about Johan saying he's done
with Danielle what's up Yohan
Danielle's ex Talon joins the tell-all
and Johan doesn't say a word to him the
most important thing to me is that Johan
understands that it doesn't matter who
I've had sex with because he is my
husband he's the person I want to be
with and no one else is a threat to that
and I want him to feel secure in that do
you think she's still interested in you
no what is he gonna say yes and make
their relationship even worse Taylin is
probably wondering how he even found
himself on 90 Day Fiance as the episode
moves along Johann who says he's
uncomfortable with Taylin being in the
same city with Danielle at the tell-all
gets even more upset after they play
this clip of Danielle talking to Taylin
during the season as soon as I made the
decision that I was moving here and I
got off that plane he was like a
completely different person being around
someone that's older and more mature I
think it's going to be huge for him
Danielle
and calling him
do they not think about the Talon when
they're filming
I would be mindful of every single word
I say or at least I would try to be
because I know if I say something messy
they're gonna play it back Danielle says
she wants Johan to feel secure in their
relationship but to be honest we never
see her uplifting him and building him
up with her words so of course if you
have that and then you bring an ex who
seems to have it all together in the
picture
johann's not going to feel safe who
would
yo come on
Daniel
is
Johan tells Danielle as soon as their
lease is up their relationship is done
which in my opinion is like
come on
it reminded me of high school when
people would stay in relationships for
the remainder of the year because they
have to see that person every day
if you want to be done if you really
want to be done you're not going to wait
for a date
and it also had me confused because
Danielle claims she pays the rent so
what is he waiting for
speaking of that let's get into that
conversation about finances and the
power struggle in their relationship
like at any time I will give up all
control over all things have you said
that's him before I think that I've
always asked him to be an equal partner
you know I've always that's not good
that's not you giving up control there's
a difference between equal partners and
being submissive if I don't control a
thing it doesn't get done that's my
experience with Johan I don't want to do
all the things I would love for him to
take control over some things but if I'm
not home right now I don't pay the rent
the rent isn't getting paid
um
that's tough I'm not even gonna lie we
saw that firsthand this season when
their lights went out during the middle
of filming because Johan didn't say
anything about the Bill and Danielle
just got back in town he didn't pay for
the light
for an alpha woman a responsible man is
a turn on and when you're not one uh
so I get that she wants Johan to step up
and mature in certain ways being fine is
not just going to do it and I'm not
saying that's his only good quality of
course not but what I am saying is that
I can see how it's hard for her to treat
him like the head of the household when
he isn't moving like the head of the
household moves and unfortunately I
think that trickles into a lack of
respect for him in other areas
Danielle is that true do you guys split
things 50 50. now the the locally no
no we don't spend everything
at this point I think johann's feeling
embarrassed understandably I know they
signed up to share their life with the
world but geesh hearing your partner
tell everyone how you're missing the
mark
that's tough Danielle suggests that they
go to therapy to work things out but
Johan says he's not interested I don't
think that this relationship is really
over but I also never have any idea how
he's going to respond
I am always going to fight for my
marriage like I love my husband very
much like we're both very emotional we
both say things we don't mean we're
angry and we both need to work on that
but we're both coming into this
relationship with so much trauma that we
need someone to help us work through it
and I'm hoping that I can convince him
to consider therapy um all right that's
a wrap for the other way next week
before the 90 days is back with seven
brand new couples and Gino and Jasmine
if you could sum your storyline up this
season in the one word what would it be
chaotic
chaotic yes that's usual for Jasmine and
Gino from what we've seen at least yes I
recently spoke with Jasmine and we
talked about it all from if Gino is
still clinging to those hats what to
expect this season if she's gotten
better with her temper I have anger
issues so yeah there is cecila super
jealous controlling Jasmine plus her
cosmetic procedures and more make sure
you subscribe to entertainment tonight's
YouTube channel so you don't miss the
interview also coming up Debbie and I
take a look back on her most memorable
moments from this season well looking
back Miss Debbie do you regret getting
on the donkey oh not at all
I'd get right back up in the saddle keep
your eyes open for that one too all
right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with E.T because we are covering
it all I will see you next time